the clips watching if there's a push for
security skies will take out / no and
look at this Eclipse with one to four
eclipses
oh this is winnable they will need to
defuse and the time running out but it
clipped Wow
but rogue will take it a trade to finish
things off how does this happen
guys this ain't csgo it's not Call of
Duty and it sure as [ __ ] is an overwatch
this is Rainbow six siege and for our
first our six best of we're taking a
look at the best attacker place now
unfortunately that means no to chunka
right but it does mean some pretty sick
rushes they're rushing this thought I
know it's clear they're just gonna head
right on down and there's nothing to
stop them right now some absolutely but
clenching clutches oh my god the 1v1
that's what beat there's no time and of
course just those sick plays and multi
kill moving in not checking much there's
still a lot of time to use the breach
charges and OH so let's get it started
with one of the plays attackers do best
the rush so you've got a blitz a lion
and a token and they're just gonna
immediately oh and they're just probably
gonna sprint right in I imagine that
this is going to be a very fast round no
matter who waits yeah absolutely nine
line catching pulse off-guard in the
main lobby talent from behind using that
DMR will get the headshot Canadian goes
down and here comes the rush Ronin
already inside of laundry forcing these
defenders back as the mirror windows go
up young through the wall will get the
kill though cookies reciprocate says he
pushes through the main hallway and
Ronin for the first time looked like
they have a chance and their own
dominance in this match this is a
wonderful cheese trap that we see right
now but Yugi is able to come up no more
to live in the neck rocks and begin to
exit out Road in what that took 45
seconds and that route is over there's
no Giga coming out for face on that
defense and he looks like we shouldn't
see a 5 but pushed straight into the
garage is looking very nice from boot
camp on the site see how quickly this
gonna happen
dream it's that strange from bootcamp
straight in to the bank carriage and
they're just all in here right now
there's gonna roll all the way through
three of the stairs probably they can
see that this is all actually reinforce
surely they have Jones in position here
to know that this is going on as the
Lions go out the joke pickles go through
by they act completely called by so
price Anatole takes him down the galley
with a triple kale just three on to the
site one be five all of a sudden what an
amazing rush from boot camp
tellers archives in this is match point
this could be over very very fast
they're just gonna sprint right in and
cut through the site cleave right
through vitality but doesn't look
there's anybody on site don't get a
plant off within a thirty Seconds
vitality is so committed that no
vitality everybody is still alive the
good news is that this is still winnable
for vitality but they'll retake and all
the sites will be trained on all the
various members Fabien Koga Penghu can
we see canto and yonas pickup kills the
stew left gear for vitality Brit can get
the first one for his team though as
Penghu goes down watching the visa flank
the fire bolts in the back hall are
going to prevent any potential pushes
but Goga will also take out Brit leafing
spark and one versus four and he has no
time now guys being an attacker means
more than just taking a site and
dropping that defuse you're gonna wait
45 agonizing seconds while that goes to
work all while the retake comes in man
this is this is a tactic anti climactic
ending of I've ever seen one just
frustrated
I want to see this enclosure digest this
is the frustration and Fox ultimately
winning out with a knife right so let's
take a look at some of the attackers who
held their nerves in some pretty hairy
situations with the best clutches on the
attacker side the other will find astros
playing a bog and i'ma cut down one of
the row
on phases behalf Great Muta the double
Goga and yellowness vanquished leaving
canto raquet II to deal with the three
remaining members of phase and very
quickly he will reduce it to two with
maringá and yuna just waiting but the
shotgun a maringá looking at the corner
of the doorway canto doesn't think he
can vault he sees the mirror for a
second his position in bathroom given
away but he's gonna give himself easy
access in towards service and this is a
very winnable position with that r4c in
the hands of the Finn I need to grab the
defuser it's quite a ways away moringa
burrowed with the shotgun blast canto
around the corner silencing the crowd
hunkering will not get lead off kill
this time but bridge will get paid for
by rips as he takes to down with them
several imitating para and it's 3v3 that
diffuser in the hands of bale getting
planted and they will stick the landing
rips a third kill knock KS eliminated
from be boo the glass looking for a
fourth tries to behead people inside a
dirt tunnel man can't land it goes for
another shot before helium now it's only
up to the class they need to drop at the
same time and hopefully they'll be able
to hold off that DMR but they are
running out of time smart starts to
defuse BB looking for the class tries to
take out the yellow rip support is he
gonna get it tries to shoot away unable
to get grip the ACE and what up takes it
it Clips watching if there's a push
through security skies will take out
slash though it
look at this Eclipse with one two for
eclipse all this is winnable they will
need to defuse and the time running out
but it clicked the road will take it a
trade to finish things off how does this
happen
c4 is gonna get thrown by BC won't hit
anybody but they do spot both players
moving in problem is both players coming
to the same position all they can do is
just show them out BC gets one can't get
the second that'll be a quick drop from
Vale spots the second takes him out as
well and then the third Valkyrie all on
Canadian canny clutch this the in-game
leader the infamous player from one of
the most famous players in the entire
game
you see the bomb might get set up c4
it's gonna get throw but he's not ready
for and goes in for the night oh my god
fail gets the kill canadian gets dropped
and what up kid not believe this kill
sexy cake we'll take up yoga from inside
of bucha but he uh second one for sexy
cake he should have gone down and you
cool actually down him one the last
defender here he has to it down
attackers as well
three people crawling on the floor a
1vs1
and oh no sexy cake though has picked
himself back up because he's playing
Sophia and he's gonna be able to push
one with the pre fires narrow makes it
what just happen another logic bomb is
the smoke will choke out shuttle he'll
toss it a smoker Nate of his own and
push it with the alcohol twelve all a
great shot all the way across to marry
you a long angle with a recoil that can
be quite unwieldly to control huh see
you race hill inside a connector he's
got great position but he loses his
shuttle and another one nearly fulfill
he misses the judge but the flick behind
there's only a one for left in general
what is going on an incredible clutch
from shuttle so we've seen some of the
best openers and some of the best round
Enders on the attackers side but what
about everything in between
let's take a look at some sick plays and
multi kills you know he's out goddamn
okay he did a jitter he's one to open
the wall but blip barely banjee crazy
going for the opportunity
yeah it's gonna let Benji just sit back
up there like a gargoyle again somehow
not being killed
cats dropped in second kill this time
under breezy
he's going for a sir that's the echo
inside a projector Benji absolutely on
fire all the kills for his team in this
round Yeti will read frag on the snake
name but Benji ahora the doc is not and
breakthrough this time which of course
heady he's definitely gonna check but
he's gonna smartly leave a drone for
some overwatch here up on the fan is
also gonna get spotted was bad we're in
a mid 22 we're still nowhere near
getting on the satan these holes that
have been opened the satan definitely
works the other way again stroke I like
those stuns just giving off that there
above there that gives it up warning for
the sea force that flows well but Walker
gets to kill anyways in / problem with a
position that walk is in is that that
you could not contest them for the front
but he's tell us to remember how bond I
just already opened this position they
have not opened the mirror window now
they'll get info and Waka wool spot all
right through the mirror we know
unfortunately here for easily this is an
angle that he might be able to detest no
of course Lee he takes just a bit of
damage there a walk I guess the second
one he clips though we'll get one
turning it into a 2v2 and I'm they
pushing on the site the bed will lose
out on this he Clips the last alive on
the Ella spots the head and take that
day for what the ace for waka in the
round but they were looking for an early
pick didn't happen no problem can move
back yeah push through with us that's
the great call based effort because he
had a limited angle if he didn't get
something from it he needs to move on
otherwise he's just burning up time he
could end up in a clique situation oh-ho
there we go he's gonna be avian Birdman
is down for yeah unfortunate wasn't able
to use it and now we see Bosco setting
and here we go the timing let's see if
he can play this is Vince yes he can
tripping is gonna fall to the floor and
right next to stink Nate but Bosco is
ready for him takes him down with a
pulse laxing just moving it not checking
much there's still a lot of time to use
the breach charges
Oh what Wow
God is going down what how does that
even happen
but the thing is with Geo the way he's
able to control that means oh speaking
of which just tap tap you're done a shot
by Geo troughs or boss and I'm really
surprised by the market setup here
they're looking like they're wanna play
for a retake of meeting top floor and
they're just not having the time control
nice desire to stop this plant fuel that
another one on the Hungary don't like
off on the glass once again don't wanna
be a no geo continuing the run and he's
not gonna stop anytime soon
plank completed by eg and they all bail
out for the post plan while revenues
feet away from the attempted defuse
lights up the backside and panic man
completed onto nvk young taking a little
bit of damage panics with another one so
it's down to only a one bad deficit Gio
missing this job's for the first time
he's got the angle on the diffuser and
there's Canadian coming up spiral the
end revans run it's all of the panics is
over healing there's healing back up to
a 100 it's only real option here is the
drop is Canadian has spiraled covered
this is gonna be one peek in from Gio's
he tries to rush the front door
Gio going for 4k and
gonna nail at geometrics evil geniusness
well guys that's it for this week's best
up now if you do want to see more
Rainbow six content and if you want to
see the defender version of this best of
well let us know in the comments below
hit the subscribe button and we'll try
to make it happen thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]